hi everyone it's jerry i'm on chess.com
tactics channel i'm going to try three
more puzzles
and just take you through
my thought process which with each of
these
so okay
uh this first one team black
okay
uh that seems pretty straightforward
or does it
okay well my first thought is to take
here it's the most forcing move
with the pawn
pawn takes king g1 is necessary
otherwise we're just promoting
what would be the follow up after that
pawn takes king g1
my first thought is to try and get to
the back rank
i don't see a convenient way to do that
though
hmm
oh
actually i do see the answer
this is sneaky
huh okay well
what actually just ran through my mind
right there that
made me think of rook takes pawn
i think what just happened there is that
i recognized a pin
i believe the first move is rook takes
pawn and after rook takes to not take
back
but instead play the sneaky move f2
that's
pretty cute there
there's no way to stop the pawn from
promoting then i think that's it
interesting rook takes pawn rook takes
rook
and then f2
that's a pretty cool puzzle i like that
uh tactical motif
that is correct and then f2 sneaking
right by and that's it problem solved
how do you like that
that was cool all right let's try this
second one
that's i think maybe one of the first
times i've seen that type of a
motif before
all right
once again as black in this one
all righty
hmm how we doing materialize pretty
balanced
pond wise
okay we're down upon
but the white king is without
that g pun
we could take the bishop
but white is in a position to take here
okay uh what else
is there to note here
rook takes here
um
okay i think i see it
i think it is rook takes bishop
allow this bishop to be taken and the
reason i'm i don't know that this is
correct but the reason i'm
testing out this variation right now is
because
i'm record i'm seeing that after bishop
takes bishop the queen is restricted and
that's usually not a good position to be
in
additionally i'm seeing a way that we
can take advantage of some pin
or make use of the pin a pin with rook
takes bishop bishop takes
bishop and then rook to d3
and the bishop can't move uh well it can
move but surprisingly enough there's a
good resource if bishop takes bishop our
bishop takes pawn check
having a discovered attack against this
unprotected rook on d3 at that point
there is queen takes
firing a check right back
additionally there is after rook takes
bishop bishop takes bishop
rook d3 if let's say
rook to d1
one of the one of the rooks
you can just take the rook because at
the end of it there would be queen g4
with the check
pointing at the the king
the king in d1
so i think this is it i think we could
just go straight in for grabbing the
bishop
initially i was thinking rook takes
bishop bishop takes and then queen check
but i'm not sure what the great
follow-up would be after that
okay i'm going to run with it
let me let me just see for one more
second here
rook takes bishop would there really be
anything other than bishop takes bishop
here
i don't think so
okay so let's get rid of their light
square bishop that is correct and this
is what i was thinking rook d3
problem solved yeah that was the trick
just making use of the pin and also
there's no way to defend the bishop with
rook d1 because of queen g4
hitting at both g1 and d1 all right
let's see if we could go
three for three
with this last one here
playing as white this time okay
hmm
all right i don't believe there's any
good
checking moves to start actually then i
take that back
okay firstly the queen is hit
and uh i'd really like to get at this
square but the knights protecting the
knight we could say is in fact
overloaded
having to watch over e6 from a check
and also f5
so
what does this mean it means we could
play maybe rook to e6
and after knight takes rook there's
queen takes pawn
which is in fact mate
okay so that's pretty serious rook e6 in
other words cannot be taken by the
knight
queen takes f5 and that's it that would
be mate so rook e6 as a start
is probably it
black doesn't have to take however and
as it stands right now material wise
uh black is up a pawn
rook e6 check king f7 what do we do
there oh we have a great move
knight takes d6 with the fork
okay
rook e6 king h7 what would we have at
that point
um my senses are telling me to like
sacrifice on h6
it's worth noting that we can't we have
to be quite forceful because as soon as
this queen leaves the second rank black
has
uh pressure against g2 so i believe it's
important
to take that into account to realize
that if we are not
very forceful with the
the moves we're making or at least
considering
then
black has this checkmate on g2
so rook e6 check
king f7 we land a fork
on d6
if king h set i think going forward i'll
consider those last because i think it's
just running into
more trouble with these pawns being able
to contribute to controlling squares
around the black king
so i'm thinking rook e6 we know what
happens on king f7 king h7
would we do there rook e6 king h7
rook takes
king takes
queen h4 check
king g6
queen f6 check
if the king comes here
i think there'd be knight g7 so rook e6
king h7
rook takes h6 king takes rook
queen h4 check king g6 it's an only move
at that point queen f6 would force
king h7
and then
hmm
queen is on f6 at this point this rook
is captured
or this rook is just not on the board no
rook in this variation i'm trying to
visualize right now there's no white
rook there's no black pawn
and this queen is relocated on f6 and
the black king is on h
seven what would be the good follow up
there i don't think there is a good one
not seeing it queen g7 square is covered
um am i going down the wrong path it
might be
it kind of it kind of feels like i don't
i don't see what the good
follow-up would be there i don't see a
good check at that point
hmm wait a second why am i not
considering queen here in my first move
what's the matter with me
why am i so fixated on rook e6 what's
wrong with this check oh my goodness
oh man okay let's go with this
queen g3
why am i getting all fancy with rook e6
that might not still be a bad move but
okay let me consider this as the first
the first one queen g3
king here we play queen g7 and there
goes the black queen
okay
um
king here we give mate with knight f6 so
after queen g3 king h7
and
what about
knight f6 is the follow up
that looks to be pretty good
yeah okay wait queen g3 king h7
knight f6 check king h8
and i think there might be
one quiet move in this position
queen to g6
which is threatening
many or i don't know many but a couple
things
queen takes h6
and then the queen would have to block
queen takes h7 mate
and also rook to e8
for example and i think this is my this
is how my uh play out queen g3
king h7
knight f6 check king h8 and then after
queen to g6 i think there's just too
many threats for black to defend
if queen g7 to defend h6 there comes now
rook e8 check rook takes rook queen
takes rook
the king at that point is in the corner
the black queen is right here
and she's gonna have to block on one of
these two squares and we just take the
queen and it's going to be mate
i think that's it
notice how in this variation the queen
on g6 is still around to watch over that
main threat that black has on g2
i'm gonna run with it
it is correct okay
night check
that is correct and one quiet move
queen g6
that is correct queen here no okay i
think
well we just take the rook here
no tricks
that'll be a problem solved yeah
i got in the analysis board i'm pretty
sure that that would in fact be the case
see if i could
get this board lined up somewhat close
so this is what i was referring to no
not that let's try this one more time
there we go
okay
this rook here this is how the puzzle
started here here
check
queen g6 the computer i think could have
also gone with this
i thought that would have been the one
to
really know how exactly to follow up on
the white side there would follow rook
check
it takes where a queen takes rook and
then
it's going to be made on the next move
so that was interesting i'm glad i
finally went into a different direction
i was testing out rook to e6 for
a little bit there but
queen g3 is uh going to be the solution
to this third puzzle
okay well those are the only three that
i'm going to do and as always i hope you
got something out of it take care bye
hmm
okay
oh i got it
i got this one
let me make sure i don't slip up though